hi Samuel leaves here and I am with
possibly the most famous estate agent in
the West Midlands at the moment so
welcome to Melissa Shervington
yeah from Amity estates amis you press a
right Aventine properties you are very
famous right now and you're in the news
and and everything like that for a funny
story which is maybe not funny I don't
know it depends how you look at it okay
why don't you just introduce yourself
and tell us what you do okay so my name
is Melissa serving ttyn I'm the owner of
Amity properties we're an independent
estate agent and we're based in Sutton
Coldfield and we offer residential
lettings and sales great and when I saw
the the papers about what you did part
me thought why is this in the news it
was kind of funny
but interesting but I mean basically you
don't want me saying it's kind of it's
in the news so that the title is estate
agents over-the-top ad is the best thing
you'll read today yeah so that that's
the thing so how does it feel that the
the national press are saying that the
best thing that you could ever read
today is your writing well it's amazing
to be honest when I first saw the ad I
must admit I had a slight meltdown and I
did think I can't believe this is
happening
however once had read its and digested
it I realized that it was actually an
amazing opportunity and our copy has
been recognized yeah and you've not just
hit the news once you've hit the news
twice yeah and and you just yesterday
we're now in the national news yes
that's just insane is it okay for just
recently yeah that's fine
all right so okay to be honest this
place Elvis this place sells itself it
really does it is a mansion but it
hasn't stopped the Thomas Hardy like
descriptions from following Mallory's
friendly combination of curl curves and
turns may trigger a wave of happiness
tell Jeff or seaside Britain of
yesteryear as you soak up it's still
like for Art Deco structure that's what
use that those were your
that's our coffee that's amazing you're
a good writer and then they said what we
thought is this is a fine-looking house
and the estate agent is right to point
out it's lovely curves but not sure
we're getting that seaside feeling here
well they'll have to book it just goes
on and they basically just like read
your descriptions find it hilarious say
what you said and then say what they
thought and and that made the news so
but if we look at the final line do you
know what the final line was in their
article gone so where do we sign on the
dotted line
so obviously lured them in that's what
they said at the end that's what they
said at the end so you did manage to
sell the house not not not not actually
of course this is just but i mean you
sold the house to the press and the plan
is to now actually sell the house that's
the plan so not only have you been in
the hit the media warms you actually
don't twice now what's yesterday or the
day before whenever it's a Saturday
Birmingham Mail and just again yesterday
on props the industry I which is a
national journal for a cyber tea
industry on I is incredible the writer
who wrote all this stuff about you what
would you say to them I would say a
massive thank you and first and foremost
for actually highlighting who we are
we've recently moved into the southern
coalfield area so it's a great way for
people to get to know that yes we're
there we're operating and they've really
highlighted our copyright which then has
led to hundreds and hundreds of people
clicking onto the description online so
we've had great exposure yeah
do you see the funny side to the article
at all or do you think edge did yes I do
now I do think the videos I've got to
get however they've done me a favor yeah
but do you do you see the funny side a
little bit or not I do I do I can now
read it and actually have a chill that's
good because when I read it I thought it
was hilarious
yeah I'm glad you did and many people
actually did and if you look at the
comments that there are really positive
comments in the better people thought it
was funny but actually we're on your
side that's because that was when I read
it I thought is I thought you know the
law is really funny but then I thought
to be fair Melissa has done a really
good job here you know writing so well
and selling the house is it normal for
estate agents to write this
this way it's not not for every estate
hey do we engage a professional
copywriter so that has an I haven't
written the whole article oh do so being
such a professional copywriter they
interview the homeowners and what our
aim is to really tap into the hearts and
minds of the people who live in the
homes so that then can be captured into
amazing copyright as it has done which
takes people on a journey so they can
get an essence and an experience of what
does it actually feel like to live in
this property it's about selling a
lifestyle yeah you are how much input
did you have in the in the description
to drive anyone on
so we basically steer so we we would
engage the copyright so give them as
much information as we can explain what
the features are with the property then
they interview the homeowners directly
and then from that they come up with a
draft and then we work with the
copyrights okay so you kind of oversee
it yes you're so good at descriptive
language and and and creative and
describing things I wonder if you could
maybe describe me I think Samuel is an
amazing character bursting with with
character
yeah that's the word that comes to mind
character love that bursting with
character hi-fi's authentic oh wow
these days you know what I so get your
you and your copy writers to write a
blog on me yeah so what you're looking
to do then over the next sort of twelve
months in the Birmingham area
well Sutton Coldfield is where our
focuses and surrounding and I mean as I
said we're new to the area we've
relocated we've been there for a mere
two weeks already we've already hit the
press so we are now targeting special
properties so we're on the hunt for more
unique homes premium homes which may be
on the market and struggling to sell
we've been there for several months and
in some cases even years and that's
because the photography and the copy is
just plain old boring so our job is to
come in and really shake up reinvent the
marketing and relaunch it right that's
right so if anyone happens to be
watching this from the press then
fingers up and thank you for the for the
coverage if you're watching this and
you've got a really nice house because
this is like a room
in fact I saw this and didn't know it
was on with you right and I thought wow
this house looks great I saw I'm writing
it because I regularly just yessiree
mansions for inspiration and then I saw
the news article I was like oh my gosh
this is Melissa because we've known each
other for years I have yes
and and and then here we go so if you
happen to have a mansion that you're
wanting to sell in the Sutton Coldfield
area then this is your girl I mean
you've had so many hits on right now
yeah you've got this house on the
national news so that's amazing
another thing is that there's got to be
some lessons from this story yeah keep
on keepin on keep them coming
yeah yeah what would you what advice
would you give to an entrepreneur
watching this video that wanted to be
maybe noticed in the way that you are
maybe wanted to hit get getting the
press I mean what advice would you give
cuz you've done really well my advice
would be don't be afraid to be different
disrupt the marketplace I mean for
myself I'm in a highly competitive
industry there were thousands of estate
agents and everyone's competing for that
property but you've got to be different
and being different means being bold
means stepping out breaking the norm and
being really creative in the way
properties are marketed so in any
industry it's about being different
being unique that's brilliant and most
estate agents they just have the same
old techniques same old tricks you've
come and being really different and
you've been notice for that yeah so I
guess if you're an entrepreneur watching
this be different don't try to be
different and also you know what I love
about you Melissa they work they they
kind of came on to take the mick oh yeah
and you've managed to flip the cards and
turn it into a good thing yes and
someone once said in fact my Pastor Gary
spicy he said take what you do seriously
but don't take yourself seriously and
that's the key and the fact you've even
come on this show and you're just be
light-hearted have a chuckle about what
the press are saying and flip the cards
is incredible yes is incredible so final
words of wisdom final words of wisdom
ease step out be bold and be different
amazing Melissa's contact details are
going to be on the description below
be in touch if you want to sell your
house or you want to contact Melissa and
we look forward to seeing you next time
Thank You Samuel Jase why five man I
sent thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that video please do
share it with your family
friends for more videos like it you can
watch right here and if you'd like to
spend two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time